foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter Theory
Theory today we're going to be diving
into a little detail of the story that
casual Harry Potter fans might not ever
even think about this detail involves a
certain protagonist Harry Potter and a
certain antagonist Voldemort more
specifically it relates to the
connection between the two characters on
One fateful late October evening October
31st to be specific in the year 1981
Lord Voldemort at the height of his
power traveled to godrick's Hollow in
the home of the Potters it was on this
night that the course of history changed
as Voldemort had traveled there with one
goal in mind kill the boy when he
entered their home he first ended the
life of James Potter and then began
making his way towards Lily and baby
Harry when Voldemort approached Lily he
asked her to step aside and let him have
Harry to somewhat honor Snape's wishes
he told Lily that if she stepped aside
that he would spare her life but
obviously Lily's Main priority was
protecting Harry because she wouldn't
get out of the way she was murdered by
Voldemort's killing curse shortly after
Lily had Hit the Floor Voldemort turned
his wand on Harry his Target and he knew
that he was moments away from killing
the only boy or wizard that was a threat
to him and his regime however what would
happen next is something that he never
could have predicted as after firing a
killing curse at Harry his curse
rebounded back at him this was the
result of a loving sacrifice that Lily
had made sacrificial protection when the
curse came back at him it destroyed him
and it marked the end of Voldemort for a
time but it also tragically marked the
end of The Potters
but Voldemort's curse rebounding off of
Harry wasn't all that happened you see
on that night a connection was formed
between the two of them Voldemort's Soul
was so destabilized through creating
horcruxes that part of it actually split
off when he was hit by the backfiring
curse when a piece of the soul is ripped
from one's body generally there needs to
be somewhere for a bit to go Q baby
Harry as Harry was the only living thing
in the room it latched itself to Harry
which effectively formed the connection
that we later know Harry and Voldemort
to have Harry wasn't a poor Crux so to
speak as no traditional horcrux creation
process took place but a connection with
Voldemort there certainly was now a
connection to the dark lord definitely
brings with it a lot of baggage Harry
had a lot of unexplainable things happen
to him some mysterious some useful but
mostly banned one of the abilities
transferred to Harry was the ability to
speak big parcel tongue he became a
parcel mouth parcel tongue is more
commonly known as the language of snakes
a hereditary trait passed on through
descendants of salazars that they're in
but while speaking another language is
actually kind of a cool bonus one
massively negative aspect of their
connection was their interconnected
Minds because part of Voldemort's Soul
was inside of Harry they had insights
into each other's thoughts and feelings
and are not sure that Voldemort is
someone you want inside of your head
periodically Harry would have episodes
involving a burning Scar and strange
unexplainable Visions where he saw
Voldemort committing atrocities he could
often see where Voldemort was and what
he was doing Harry didn't want to see it
but interestingly Voldemort didn't
really want him to see it either at
least not later in the story which is
why he began to practice occlimency the
art of magically closing one's mind to
those who attempt to invade it generally
through legilimency in the Order of the
Phoenix Voldemort leveraged the
Connection in order to trick Harry but
by the Half-Blood Prince he'd realized
this was dangerous territory Harry
didn't try to invade Voldemort's mind
but he was doing it anyway autonomously
which meant that Voldemort taking action
and Performing occlimency was essential
in keeping his thoughts unread in
chapter 4 of the Half-Blood Prince
Dumbledore enlightens Harry so tell me
Harry said Dumbledore your scar has it
been hurting at all Harry raised a hand
unconsciously to his forehead and rubbed
the lightning-shaped mark no he said and
I've been wondering about that I thought
it would be burning all the time now
Voldemort's getting so powerful again he
glanced up at Dumbledore and saw that he
was wearing a satisfied expression I on
the other hand thought otherwise said
Dumbledore Lord Voldemort has finally
realized the dangerous access to his
thoughts and feelings you've been
enjoying it appears he is now employing
occlimency against you okay so Voldemort
real is the potential danger and letting
Harry see his thoughts and started
blocking him out makes sense but what
doesn't make sense is that in the very
next book The Deathly Hallows Harry
seems to be right back in his head again
this leaves the question of why did
Voldemort stop using occlimency why did
he reopen that bridge to Harry's Mind
through glimpses into Voldemort's mind
Harry was able to gain a lot of useful
information that's inevitably LED
towards Harry's safety and Voldemort's
downfall he learned that Voldemort was
on his way to godrick's hollow and to
Malfoy Manor he became aware of
Voldemort's obsession with the Elder
Wand and most importantly he became very
aware of Voldemort's fear that his
horcruxes were being discovered he even
revealed to Harry that his last horcrux
was hidden inside the walls of Hogwarts
Voldemort exposed himself to Harry time
and time again which makes me wonder why
was it arrogance or something else why
allow your enemy into your mind
willfully as it turns out JK Rowling has
been asked this very question before in
an interview how come Voldemort was no
longer employing occlimency against
Harry as he was in the sixth book he is
losing control and unable to prevent
Harry's seeing into his mind the
connection between them is never fully
understood by Voldemort who does not
know that Harry is a horcrux what
Rowling explains here is that Voldemort
never made the decision to allow Harry
into his mind it's just that he was no
longer able to properly keep him out
with the stressful State of Affairs and
his horcrux is being destroyed left and
right Voldemort was losing control it
seems as though vodmore's mental state
has a huge impact on whether or not
Harry can infiltrate his thoughts if
Voldemort loses control of his emotions
whether that's through anger or
frustration he simply forgets to apply
occlimency allowing Harry inside even if
only just for a moment Voldemort never
knew that a bit of his Soul was inside
of Harry so he never really had any
explanation for their mental link to
Voldemort a master of the mind
anoclemency there's no way that he could
possibly think that Harry would be able
to access his thoughts at any moment
he probably knew that he stopped
employing a clemency momentarily in
these fits of Rage but never thought
that Harry would be able to capitalize
on these tiny Windows of time
Harry finds out about gregorovich just
as Voldemort is about to murder him
thrilled with the prospect of ending a
life and perhaps momentarily forgetting
to apply occlimency amidst the
excitement Harry finds out about the
Elder Wand just as Voldemort finds it
high on a sense of Triumph and
accomplishment
Harry finds out the Rowena ravenclaws
diadem is at Hogwarts after Voldemort
finds out that they broke into
bellatrix's vaults subsequently
exploding with anger Harry finds out
that Voldemort is on his way to Hogwarts
when Voldemort realizes that the locket
is missing these bursts of emotion both
negative and positive were the reasons
that Harry was able to gain insight into
Voldemort's movements and that's it for
this video did you guys ever wonder why
Voldemort's mind appeared to be so
easily accessible by Harry if you enjoy
the content please like the video
subscribe to the channel and leave a
comment down below until next time
remember the truth it is a beautiful and
terrible thing and should therefore be
treated with caution
foreign